so so if there's an opportunity for
these corporations for the elites why
isn't this stuff getting done
why would you when the people in power
just fight each other
as long as long as we maintain
this
two you know left right dichotomy there
is literally no need to fix anything we
just fight each other right if you look
at any i'm i'm the oddball here if you
look at anyone else running go to their
website and look for policy you will
find none
what you will find is
other guy bad
america other guy bad america that's
what you'll find and that happened since
believe not al gore in 2001 all
consultants tell
their their people don't put detailed
policy on your website because then your
enemies will attack you on it let me
don't put it on i think the opposite
third party has to we don't get noticed
without it i want to i want to read for
everybody a text message i received
today
proving your point
um i don't know if i should read the
guy's name should i he's a problem in
the office all right i'm not gonna read
his name but i gotta he says uh hi tim
he says hi timothy this is candidate for
congress in new jersey's second
congressional district i i tried calling
today to introduce myself i'm a lifelong
new jerseyan and civil rights attorney
with a 27-year long career in law
enforcement and i'm running for congress
to replace turncoat jeff van drew there
we go uh i'm trying to build an early
staff would love your money it's not the
first uh tax i've received i also
because it's it's tis the season right
um let me see i got another one in here
somewhere here we go
uh let's see
who is this one okay here we go hi tim
it's candidate the dirt road democrat
that will defeat the queen of q and on
marjorie taylor green in november i said
you know what man
i've gotten a bunch of these tax from
democrats and all of them are like i
hate this person so give me money yes
that's all of them that way what we
what's happened now again this is the
left for us to fight paradigm it's now a
point where my victory is you losing
my victory isn't me winning my victory
is you losing so your pain is my joy
who wins with that no no one no one this
is gandhi's eye for an eye and we all go
blind this is not the way of doing
things it's got to be how do we fix
things that make that makes things
better i can't get past the other guy
bad if i don't have a solution my point
is
if i can show someone that my way will
make their life better i have a chance
of them voting for me and i still get it
when i add idea when it came to cannabis
right and i said let's regulate cannabis
like onions
it's a plant very like onions let
farmers grow if they want to grow a
craft grow in new york state if you're
poor grow your medicine in your backyard
right if you have my my saying was if
you like your deal keep your dealer
right because because you don't have to
get a special license for it right it's
a plant right so regular onions oh good
people still talk about that like i'll
be in i'll be in new york a car will
drive by roll the window down go larry
sure regularly like onions literally
that will still happen that's that's the
point i was talking about earlier with
it which is for every policy you want to
have a policy that is you know radical
enough for someone to notice it but
familiar enough
for someone to accept so regulate oh
that's familiar like onions that's weird
because there really aren't that many
regulations on onions in new york there
are too many probably probably like
carrots or something but i don't care
you pick the vegetable regular like a
vegetable now oh it's different it's a
plan this is why i really liked um
andrew yang
and who i've forgotten saying was marion
williamson yes marianne williamson i
really i really felt bad for her but i
really uh
it was quite endearing when she was on
the stage and she was like i don't want
to talk bad about people right you know
they were trying to ask her something
and she was like i don't want to have to
do this right and i was like i respect
that but man did she get roasted
by the establishment corporate press
they called it the crystal woo-woo lady
and all that stuff and she's like i
don't know any crystals i don't
understand
andrew yang you know i was a fan i'm not
that big of a fan right now he's okay i
give him a c minus i was at i had him at
an a plus before and it was because his
website was load with policy i was like
man he's got a policy for everything i
love it he's like hey i actually thought
about these things i want to fix them
yes but then i feel like um you know
like bernie sanders like many of these
other you know politicians they decide
to play ball the establishment and walk
into that they play that game i think i
think before i think he tried that and
it didn't work and now he's out that's
why he's out and i think it's the right
move and by the way i have policy
may i promote for a second no of course
larrysharp.com that is larry sharp with
an e
and the e stands for electable so you
can uh check out larrysharp.com and i've
got all my policy there and it's most of
it's been there
for four years i've just added some more
recent policy because the state has
gotten even worse i've had the idea of a
new york new york state currency
an idea of a a stipend a yearly stipend
that comes out of new york state i've
had all these different type of ideas
but
what yang agrees with completely and me
agree completely is third party is the
only way to save the country i don't
like saying it's the only way because i
want more more political parties more
parties but at least one right it is so
hard in some if you're a democrat or
republican you may not know this but
your party actively uses your money to
sue to throw people off the ballot
they go out of their way to get judges
to remove your choice so it can remove
your voice that's what they do they do
not want a functioning democracy they
don't want primaries they want to select
the people remember with gerrymandering
the parties pick the voters the voters
don't pick the parties
so the parties pick the voters with
gerrymandering to make their decisions
on who gets what controlled opposition
and then non and then those who are in
charge
then the parties pick the leaders
so no voting in in the primary and then
gerrymandering ensures they win so
they're appointing all of these leaders
and begging you for money if there's a
chance for someone's going to lose most
of people who are begging you for money
know already who's going to win
they just want you to give money to keep
raising money it's all the grift that's
what most of them are doing you make a
third or fourth party gerrymandering is
irrelevant
right you make a third or fourth party
us versus them as relevant why is that
because if you jerry manger mander for
say republicans in one district right
most uh rural districts are
gerrymandered for republicans right most
are so most city ones are gerrymandered
for democrats generally speaking right
there's obvious exceptions but a general
rule well now it's a third party in
there
how do i know
right parties if you do it right
will be specialized parties right so
this part is gonna be heavily about
whatever
um
health care for all this one's gonna be
about free market cannabis right there's
gonna be a bunch of parties so if i'm a
republican but that was but i'm a single
issue voter on these things i'm going to
lose that republican voter from a
democrat but i'm a single wish of one of
those things i lose that voter it breaks
up it breaks up the uh the
gerrymandering i think you're right um
and full disclosure i've donated to the
forward party um for that reason there
needs to be
you know something something different
and uh
i i still think that one of the problems
is
i'm not a fan of the establishment
republicans i like the more populist
libertarian type republicans up in new
hampshire the libertarians they run as
republicans
and
the fear though is
it's our election system yes it's first
pass to the post voting you're right
people are going to say look man i get
it the republicans but i will do
anything to stop the democrats i agree
and that's why we all three parties
unite
um the libertarian party and the forward
party have what i call the bro program
yes it is bro bro b
easier ballot access to let people on
the ballot it doesn't mean you have to
vote for them but let them be on the
ballot to vote
are ranked choice voting if we don't
make ranked choice sporting happen you
are correct you're right you've got to
have a ranked choice voting to where you
can say i really like larry sharp but if
he doesn't win i like this person so i
wrote very larry show up first i really
like him
because he's really good looking so i
pick him on a total that makes no sense
except he's hot and then i go to the
next person who i think of policy is
good i think that's how trudeau won
i still get my safety net right so that
cr that we need that and last is open
primaries
so that people can vote in different if
i'm not part of a party i can sort of
decide what matters to me so say i'm
usually a democrat i'm usually a
republican but in this specific race
nobody in my party that it's running is
worth anything so i'm going to vote a
democrat this time well i don't know for
libertarian this time so i have a chance
of doing so in the primaries so ballot
access ranked choice voting open
primaries that will change the country i
dig it what do you think about the mises
caucus
i'm on the advisory board oh well there
you go yeah i i'm i will be in the
advisor of any caucus before with you um
and i've openly said that they're the
only ones who actually took me up on it
oh wow yes i offered it for when the
prague calls you i offered it for them
they didn't want me so the only ones
wanted me with them so i took it so i
we're gonna i'm open to all caucus is it
caucuses conquest i don't know i'm just
making it we're gonna have classes
caucuses president dave smith press
secretary michael malus who would be the
vp in that circumstance
has he said has anyone mentioned it
no
smith sharp do they have to be an
american
yes
you just have to live i think in new
york you have to be a resident of new
york state i think five years
that's interesting you just move in from
saudi arabia and five years later be
governor uh yeah i'm pretty sure that's
the rules it'd be you'd be over you'd be
over 30 you'd be 30 years old older and
i think a resident it's five or seven i
forgot one or two but the rest that's
i've been a resident for many decades so
it doesn't matter to me but it's a
certain number of uh years do you think
there would be value to letting
non-american citizens or people that
aren't born in the u.s run for a
president and vp at some stage in their
life
i don't know i mean i i understand why
they did it in the past because a lot of
people weren't born in america we had so
much immigration and worry about people
coming over and royalty coming over and
taking over and making american royalty
in the 1700s it made sense then i'm not
sure now to be forward to you would
would it be terrible for
for you know someone like uh you know an
immigrant who's come over and learned
the american dream to become president i
don't know yeah i think elon musk
particularly i don't know like they can
never do it it's just seems so wrong no
i i
i still agree with it but i think the
issue is
it's a it's a safety measure against
people who don't understand our culture
our values our principles unfortunately
doesn't seem to be working too well
because we had joe biden in office sure
but that's because
there is a
um
malignancy growing within this country
that opposes what the united states is
and always has been and is seeking to
supplant it and it's been growing
exponentially over the past 10 years
i'm hoping you can call this bro program
the program i don't know if is that the
program is that
i'm calling it from that one kind of
cliche
it might play worth running through
focus groups done so doing it done a bit
of a dad joke i don't know what i'm
stealing it and giving you exactly no
credit thank you just reading that's the
way it should be yes
yes the challenge on the immigration
issue is that
you know for one we're seeing a massive
influx of non-citizens pouring into the
country yes these are people who see
opportunity but don't understand the
opportunity
and so
we have we
have it's a very interesting problem you
know i've often said i have infinitely
more respect for illegal immigrants who
are risking life and limb traveling
through you know mexico
to try and come to the united states
because as an america there is a dream
of opportunity i have more respect for
them than i do the woke leftists who are
like america's inherently evil and all
of that stuff the problem is
they're both not representing or
understanding i mean certainly i think
one ideal is better than the other that
america is great is better than saying
america is bad
but we need people who understand what
it took to make sure the country was
great the freedoms liberties that allow
people to prosper
otherwise you end up with people coming
here and being like look i don't care i
got mine you end up with people being
born here saying i'm not getting mine so
i'll take it
and that's
it's a malignancy i think it's growing
in this country and it's displacing the
people who are like um you know i won't
forget the men who died who you know
made this land free or whatever the line
is right i'm not sure
that native born americans are any more
or less
um
patriotic to be fought i don't really
know if that's true i know a lot of
native among americans who do nothing
but bad mouth america well that's what
that's i know lots of people who are
immigrants who talk great about america
and the reverse i don't i don't know if
i could i'd like some data on that is
there any difference i don't actually
know it's not i guess to answer your
question it's not a big deal to me
either way to be four with you i don't
really know if it matters much i learned
a new appreciation for the united states
when i spent time in peru
when you see the national police on
every corner and like just like wow if i
slip up here the feds are on me there's
no local protection in these countries
traveling's amazing i live in japan for
many years how long uh four years
i'm teaching english there oh cool so um
i live in japan for four years i toured
china philippines korea um i was uh i
had to do some work in london and berlin
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you